hey 42 here a few weeks ago I did a
little experiment nothing too crazy I
wasn't trying to resurrect Winston
Churchill in my garage it was a food
experiment in a semi intoxicated Haze I
opened my fridge and started
sporadically slinging everything in
sight into a frying pan there was bacon
a bit of cheese a few mushrooms some
slightly old cherry tomatoes a hearty
dollop of Jarred kimchi and finally a
splash of wora
sauce I wasn't expecting much it was 2:
a.m. and 95% of my brain had already
gone to sleep but what emerged from that
seing sauce pan of a sorted shite upon
my stove was absolutely glorious it was
a meaty Savory flavor bomb that seemed
to coat my mouth with every single bite
I didn't realize it at the time but I
had inadvertently combined a selection
of foods that are rich and a naturally
occurring chemical compound one that
makes pretty much anything taste godamn
delicious it's one why pring popping
leads to not stopping and it's the
reason you'd murder your own mother for
a packet of monster
Munch now the ancient Greeks believe the
earth is made up of four elements earth
water air and fire and then science
happened and we realize that everything
that everyone has ever said before the
15th century was absolute and total crap
and now it's happening again you see
modern science had been under the belief
that there were four B BC tastes sweet
sour salty and bitter and everything we
eat was made up of some combination of
those flavors but as it turns out that's
also not true there's actually a fifth
taste that's every bit as important as
the others and yet most of us hadn't
heard of it until very recently
particularly in the West Welcome to the
finger licking world of
umami Ser shark VPN keeps you safe and
private by covering bring up everything
you do online and surf Shar VPN lets you
travel the world virtually by changing
your virtual location or if you are
physically traveling surf shark lets you
connect via your home country so you
don't have to miss out on all your home
Comforts such as streaming video content
from home that might be blocked whilst
you're traveling there are over 3,200
servers in 100 countries so anywhere
you'll go you'll find a server that fits
your needs Sur shark VPN offers a
multihop feature so you can put two VPN
servers between you and your online
destination for even more privacy and
security and I especially love surf
shar's IP Rotator feature which
constantly changes your device's IP
address without losing your VPN
connection it's really important to stay
safe online when you're out and about
and that's why I use Sur shark VPN so I
can for example access my online banking
safely even on public Wi-Fi there's no
chance I'd ever do that without a VPN
vpn's also keep your location and
download history private so you can send
and receive files securely quite simply
Sur shock VPN is an essential tool and
by using the Code 42 you'll benefit from
free extra mums for free all you have to
do is click the special link in the
description below so don't miss out and
a big thanks to Surf shark VPN for
sponsoring this video Our Story begins
in 1907 when a Japanese chemist called
kakuni aada was sitting down to eat a
bowl of dashy as he did almost every
night with his family but as he ate iida
noticed that something strange was going
on he stopped eating took a moment for
pause and declared that it was the
greatest soup he'd ever eaten something
was different as a matter of fact that
day soup was prepared with the addition
of KOMU an edible kelp eaten widely
across
Asia the soup possessed a powerful and
morish taste it was a taste he'd been
experiencing his entire life only he
hadn't really realized it until this
very moment intrigued eada dedicated all
his time to investigating why a simple
sliver of seaweed made his soup taste so
superb and then in 1908 he cracked it
ikita discovered that the taste he'd
experienced in his bowl of Dashi was
caused primarily by a single molecule an
amino acid called glutamic acid which
once digested turns into glutamate in
the body
the more Rida looked into it the more he
realized it was everywhere but certain
foods seaweed meat cheese tomatoes
soybeans and others are particularly
packed with
glutamate Ika had made a genuine
scientific discovery there was a fifth
taste and he named it Umami roughly
meaning delicious
taste but for the best part of The Next
Century no nobody really took him
seriously especially outside of Asia
it's easy to see why too the idea of a
fifth haste is pretty out there it would
be like trying to convince the world
that you found a new hole from which to
urinate but as the 20th century Drew to
a close his work began to gain Traction
in The Culinary and Science World in
2003 the word Umami was officially added
to the Oxford English Dictionary and
today it's widely accepted as the fifth
taste and touted by every Chef worth his
salt I mean Umami Umami is created for a
process called Umami Synergy where
glutamate and nucleotides combine to
create a taste that's greater than the
sum of its parts the result is a mouth
filling broth likee flavor when you eat
something and it instantly coats your
entire mouth with a deep rich almost
meaty flavor that's
Umami and as for the star of the show
glutamate you may have heard that word
before within the context of of mono
sodium glutamate if not then you
certainly heard of its acronym MSG being
a chemist ikid wanted to isolate which
variant of glutamate had the strongest
flavor enhancing effects he tried
calcium glutamate magnesium potassium
and others and then he found it mono
sodium glutamate this was the compound
he'd been searching for conveniently it
also happens to be the most soluble and
the easiest to crystallize and so that's
exactly what he did he crystallized
seaweed broth to create a powder a
powder that he could then add to any
other food during the cooking process to
supercharge its taste and mouth
feel basically ikik had created the
crack cocaine of the food
World a magic powder for chefs to cheat
their way to achieving incredible flavor
so he started a company aimoto meaning
the essence of taste the first company
in the world to manufacture MSG it's
fair to say that went pretty well today
aimoto turns over in excess of 10
billion US per year turns out there's a
lot of money to be made in ambiguous
white powders nowadays MSG is typically
made by fermenting starches like rice
corn or sugar cane and you'll find a jar
of it in almost every Kitchen in China
Thailand Japan and most of Southeast St
Asia but it has penetrated the West too
only it's had to do so in a much more
subtle way because of well to put it
bluntly Prejudice you've probably heard
of Chinese restaurant syndrome it was
even described in Maran Webster's
Dictionary as a group of symptoms such
as numbness of the neck arms and back
with headache dizziness and palpitations
that is held to affect susceptible
persons eating food and especially
Chinese food heavily seasoned with mono
sodium
glutamate the syndrome was first
mentioned in a letter in the New England
Journal of Medicine in
1968 the claims in the letter were later
found to have no basis in science but
unfortunately the damage had been done
and the idea of Chinese restaurant
syndrome and a supposed link between MSG
and negative Health consequences rapidly
gripped the American psyche it was an
easy claim to swallow after all MSG
sounds mysterious and processed and it
comes from a far away land in a strange
place called
Asia thankfully we now know better
despite countless studies there is
absolutely zero evidence to date that
consuming moderate quantities of MSG
causes headaches numbness or any other
long-term negative symptoms whatsoever
in fact no seasoning has ever been the
subject of more safety testing than
MSG so next time Karen blames her numb
toe on a PR crack craer you can safely
ignore her a jiny moto actually went on
the attack against Mary and Webster for
their description calling it racist and
unscientific and after some time they
adjusted it so yeah MSG is everywhere in
fact you probably have some in your
kitchen right this very moment it's
hidden away in all sorts of processed
foods like frozen meals canned soups and
a crapload of snacks and there's so much
MSG in one bag of Doritos you could open
a Chinese takeaway it's also a key
ingredient in the world's most popular
sources like ketchup barbecue and
mayonnaise but like I said because of
decade of unwarranted negative public
opinion about MSG it often goes by
sneaky pseudonyms in the ingredients
list such as sodium quinate hydrolized
protein and autoly yeast which sounds
like something you'd find growing on a
dead pigeon and here in lies the problem
with MSG recent studies suggest it's
actually a healthier seasoning than salt
or sugar but and this is a big but MSG
is frequently used by manufacturers to
make Bland unhealthy and non-nutritious
Foods taste absolutely amazing and so
addictive that you just can't stop
buying and eating them and honestly
that's the biggest problem with MSG it's
not the MSG itself it's the junk food
that it makes our bodies
crave but it's not all bad news Umami
can be enjoyed naturally too mushrooms
are Umami rich and super healthy as is
seaweed garlic and anies pizza is
officially the world's favorite food 5
billion pizzas are eaten every year and
I think I have a pretty good idea why
it's because I eat 5 billion pizzas
every year only joking it's because
wheat especially sourdough due to the
fermentation process is high inami
tomatoes are high in Umami and you
guessed it cheese especially parmesano
regano is very very high in Umami Pizza
especially Neapolitan is literally an
Umami Salt Fat and acid sandwich Italian
cuisine in general is plus with Umami so
it's no surprise it's universally
adored now I'm not saying Pizza is a
healthy option but when made from good
natural ingredients it's a dam site
better than all the heavily process crap
that MSG is usually added to Kakuna eada
may have been the first person to give
Umami a name but interestingly he wasn't
the first person to notice it not even
close in fact Umami has been known about
and exploited in cooking for over 2,000
years most famously in the kitchens of
ancient Rome though it's fair to say
unlike Aida they had no understanding of
the science behind the flavor the Romans
were addicted to a secret source that
they laced many of their dishes with it
was called garam and it was made by
fermenting fish guts and other
Seafood it sounds absolutely disgusting
it smells absolutely disgusting and it
probably tasted absolutely disgusting if
eaten on its own but it formed the
backbone of their Cuisine for one simple
reason it was utterly packed with Umami
a few drops in a dish transformed its
flavor you might think it sounds similar
to modern day fish Source but it was
actually more akin to wesa Source or
katoro di alichi Italian anvy Source gam
was so popular that it was exported all
around the Mediterranean as far north as
Britain and as far south as Morocco but
the Romans weren't the only ancients to
discover Umami the Chinese and the
Japanese were using Umami Rich soyer
sauce as early as the 3r century ad and
the Greeks have been using a fermented
fish sauce called garos similar to garam
since the the fifth century
BC it's actually pretty crazy to think
that the existence of umami has been
well known since ancient times and yet
it wasn't until the 20th century that we
figured out what it actually is but then
again it took us until the 19th century
to figure out the reason we
ourselves and we drink dirty water is
because there's bacteria in it so maybe
humans are just a bit slow on the uptake
so we've established that the world is
lowkey addicted to Umami and we are
always have been since the dawn of
snacks but that begs the question why
what is it about this simple amino acid
that makes us want to rip our shirts off
and bathe in soyer sauce well I'm afraid
you might find the answer a little
disturbing humans are addicted to Umami
because when we eat it we are eating
ourselves okay to be fair I'm being a
bit dramatic but allow me to
clarify imami is is principally derived
from the taste of glutamate and amino
acid glutamate isn't just something
that's added to our Foods in fact it's
produced Naturally by our
bodies glutamate plays a pivotal role in
our nervous system acting as a
neurotransmitter that helps send signals
between nerve cells it's actually one of
the most abundant neurotransmitters in
the brain amino acids like glutamate are
the building blocks for proteins which
Aid in growth repair tissue and so much
more
thus our predeliction for Umami is
Nature's Way of ensuring we indulge in
glutamate whenever we
can our tongues even have specific taste
receptors for detecting glutamate called
t1r1 and T1
R3 those are the names of The receptors
by the way not droids from Star Wars
moreover human breast milk is Laden with
glutamate meaning our affinity for and
codependency for Rami starts very early
in life breast milk provides newborns
with essential nutrients and the taste
of umami within it might serve as a
reinforcement mechanism encouraging
babies to feed so glutamate is a part of
what it means to be human it's a part of
our psyche literally acting as a
neurotransmitter glutamate is literally
the Catalyst for f so in a strange way
when we desire Umami it is Umami itself
telling us to desire it you could say
that imami isn't just one of the five
basic tastes it's the one taste to rule
them
all thanks for watching just a quick
word to say that I couldn't make these
videos without the support of my patreon
members consider joining the exclusive
42 Discord Community by supporting me on
patreon it's a great place to discuss my
videos with like-minded individuals and
myself the Link's in the description but
if you don't want to or you can't join
my patreon then please don't worry a
simple like or comment to say thanks
would also put a huge smile on my face
thank you